and chris ellis
six five right-hander or he'll get him
off the waiver wire from tampa bay we'll
tell you about his travels over the
course of his career 28 years old good
stuff fastball slider really a four
pitch pitcher
first pitch swinging giancarlo stanton
this is in foul territory for ryan mount
castle and a quick out recorded by ellis
after the war
and this time he gets him on a pretty
nasty change up
3-2 gardner will go
and rizzo will pop up
santander with a call
santander with a catch
and it's six scoreless innings against
the yankees this year for chris ellis
jordan montgomery the left-hander gets
the start for the yankees
and he's got more almost strikeout per
inning there opponent's hitting 242 5-6
record
and another two-strike but attempt and
that's gonna be it
so an unusual sequence there cedric
mullins trying to bunt his way on
down in the count with two strikes and
he will strike out
leo
on
fly ball right field gallow comes on
two outs
austin hayes could not hold on he
strikes out a nice easy
one two three inning for jordan
montgomery as the oreos go down in order
players joey gallo
34 homers and 72 rbi
high fly ball deep right field santander
back looking up sia onto the flag court
gallow goes yard and it's one nothing
yankees
that's his fifth home run in the last 11
games this is another changeup but this
one is not quite as far off the plate
but this is a tough pitch to pull
but galley's got that long reach
able to get the barrel to it and the
rest is history
and there's another walk so wade
walks right after sanchez so first and
second still one out gotta bring up
rochelle
rip to right field on the run is
santander he can't get there and it's up
against the wall
gary sanchez has to hold up he's going
to score
and because sanchez held up and wade
advances to third rochelle picks up the
rbi and the yankees lead two nothing the
walk comes back to haunt ellis
goes out there again with the slider but
this one wasn't as good as the second
strike this was up
a little bit more towards the middle of
the plate santander can't run it down
sanchez scores
wade's going to be held in third
swing and a miss
[Applause]
did a good job of keeping that pass ball
in
[Applause]
mckenna down on strike strikeout number
four for montgomery
high fly ball left field stanton comes
on
he's there to make the play and that'll
do it
no run to hit no errors and one man left
on base
richie martin sprays one to right center
field a base hit for the oriole nine
hitter
who whizzes to first and then decides to
head back so big hole in the right field
and a blooper here that's going to drop
in
martin got a little bit of a late break
but he will make it to right and cedric
mullins just lofts it a base hit
his
164th hit of the year
they do not go swinging a miss got him
on the change
six strikeouts for montgomery
numbed off the end of the bat rizzo
beats haze to the bag
for the final out no runs two hits
two men left we go to the fourth
now here's the payoff
man the change caught on this beautiful
change about strikeout number seven for
monty
right down the middle
down looking
swing and a miss
strikes out three in the inning nine for
the
game and a drive into right center field
that is going to get in there for a base
hit
splits the outfielders and goes to the
wall
stanton is going to stop at third it's a
double for rizzo
and the yankees have runners on second
and third
with two men out here in the fifth and
they're gonna walk labor
and face joey gallo
he hits one high
he hits one deep mckenna at the wall and
he makes the catch
right up near the pepsi side
joey gallo oh so close
but the orioles escaped the pip
here is the one two
and the pitch cut on them hey that's
something he has 10 strikeouts
[Applause]
swing and a miss on the curve
11 strikeouts
for montgomery
and they got it picked off oh he was
going he was leaning and he's going to
be tagged out by flavor torres play
through it
ground ball from her shut up martin gets
one martin gets two nicely done
as ryan malcastle is back in for another
round with jordan montgomery
that ball is crushed to center field
gardner back at the wall and there it is
ryan mount castle
stands alone atop the orioles rookie
home run leaderboard
his 29th home run
surpassing cal ripken jr for the most
long balls by an oriole rookie and he
left absolutely no doubt on the record
breaker
[Applause]
oh two hey swings gets underneath this
one as it goes out behind first base
rizzo checking the wall goes in for the
lead and against the fence over the ball
boy
he makes the catch austin hayes stares
in disbelief yeah it's an out oh finally
an out okay
so nice catch good catch riz
terrific
there's one away
so the orioles have the time run 90 feet
away
but they are down to their final hour
here's the glove of sanchez gutierrez
scores
there you go
a two strike two out bottom of the ninth
wild pitch and the orioles have tied it
at two two two the score bottom of the
tenth inning jones representing the
winning run at third
haynes has struck out
grounded out popped out in flight out
there's a chopper that sneaks through
cnn 2022 yankees
orioles woke up in the season series
finale hayes the hero to score jones a
3-2 final